始め
[拍手]
[音楽]
長年
うーんこいつ肇社長です皆さんアイスクリーム好きですかね土木冬の方がむしろアイス
クリーム食べたくなっちゃうんですよ
外は寒いじゃないですかけど家はあったかい2つ暖かい日にはあったかい熱いな架空
アイスクリームが最高に美味しいんでしょ
そこで皆さんアイスクリームます何が好きですかいろんなだけにはいろんなアイス
クリームがあるところですけど元のアイスクリームの2
10に君臨するものが何か層突破の鍵ってくっさーゲッターって夜中の sm の頂点
に組みあせもんそれこそがハゲんったらそんなハーゲンだぞ
2 l 買ってしまいましたラベルに l パックにナッツ力
4000円くらいですおすごいすごい古木はうわーちょっとでかいかなぁ業務用2 l
でございますサット2ペアの焼きそばなんですけど問題と見はちゃんと
高級アイファー件だっつ l です
パパ凄い凄いおっぱいだおおッぱいなおっぱいだめですかほらなんかちょっとオッパイ
とかないんだからほっぱらぽぱ何両か[ __ ]が大好きなアイスクリームの味はダメだそして
アイスクリームの頂点に君臨するハーゲンダッツ僕今日お腹ペコペコなんでこの状況
なら多分 l のアイスクリームましてハーゲンダッツですよで l の反映立っ
ちゃったら多分
あと全く嫌な大ヴォイセズ食べれるんじゃないかなと思いまして今回へ l の
ハーゲンダッツを一人ですってみると思いますめっちゃできます
って言うかなといただきます
あまいちゃんとハゲ夏だ夢含めだん
違うれちゃうよ
[音楽]
あーまあねほんとに普通に行きますとほとんど食ってきます
はぁ
キュッん
超で早く食べますん
wh
ん
tano
まあ
まあやぁアイスクリームと分かります周りが美味しいじゃないですか
雨にが溶けちゃうからとこれはついつい回りぱったりとリズムやばい
幸せで俺死にそうなんで本当に幸せならぁぁ今のところ全然飽きてないしなんかぴ幸せ
この幸せがあとどれだけ続くのかな
あっはぁ
まず行ける日がけどこれホントにマジ美味いも
おっん
持った
ちょっとから高さんくなってきました対応が下がってんのかな母
うわああ生ギター脳以外の
やっぱりもだいたいこのが痛いお腹痛い女が痛い
まあだーっ
tan
ちょっとやっぱり
無理したまだもず食べれそうなんですけどと助っ人を呼んでとりあえず何度か食べて
いこうと思います
きます
ああああああ
[音楽]
ハゲだっつってマジねー
スレだからあの美味しいですよピってるよ老杉のはいけるんじゃないかなと思ったん
ですけどちょっと無理だったんだいやハーゲンダッツなら言えるじゃないと思ってない
よ
負けてるんじゃないようなおいしいね美味しいのわかるんだけどちょっとしたが1回戦
制でず食べを
やべえ見ると違ってあげてとりあえずで何度せでもピ l を食べます
まぐうぇい
[音楽]
いやおいしいな承知なんだけどね美味しいんで欲しいブ c
あとこれだけあれば
普通それはそれだそれ行くぜっ
れたからもうあと俺たちはこれだって
ねぇ4はーはっはっは
goo
すごいずよねか胸にくるよねー
ルカなんだっん
狩野も対応可能じゃないん
ええええっ
えーよ絶対た日からだよなつっ
[音楽]
いますの3つなかったよねねじった
いやけどもう本当にラットラストスパートです
爪たよりキュアん
[音楽]
を生ん o
うん
ねええええ
はいああああこれさあいきます
ん
んをっ
me
パッ